Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. In early June 2020, the city of London was in the middle of its first lockdown issued in response to the coronavirus pandemic. For almost three months, UK residents had been ordered to stay at home to prevent spreading the virus dubbed COVID-19.
我们的节目涉及严肃且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您应用中或我们网站上本集节目的说明。2020年6月初，伦敦市正处于为应对新冠疫情而实施的首次封锁之中。近三个月来，英国居民一直被要求居家以防止被称为COVID-19的病毒传播。
When the weather was good, people would catch up with their friends and family outdoors where there was less risk of spreading the virus in the fresh air. But during the first week of June, temperatures were cool, prompting members of the public to want to socialise indoors instead. The UK government reminded its citizens to remain cautious and continue meeting outside as much as possible. Bieber Henry was a respected social worker who took the community's health and safety seriously, so as her 46th birthday approached on Friday June 5, she decided to celebrate with a sunset picnic in a local park instead of a party at home. Restrictions on movement meant that only loved ones who lived within walking distance could attend, and it would be a fairly small gathering.
天气好的时候，人们会去户外与亲友聚会，因为在新鲜空气中传播病毒的风险较低。但在6月的第一周，气温转凉，促使公众转而想在室内社交。英国政府提醒公民保持谨慎，并尽可能继续在户外会面。比巴·亨利（Biba Henry）是一位受人尊敬的社会工作者，她非常重视社区的健康与安全，因此随着6月5日星期五她46岁生日的临近，她决定在当地公园举行日落野餐来庆祝，而不是在家中聚会。行动限制意味着只有住在步行距离内的亲友才能参加，这将是一个相当小型的聚会。
Undeterred, Beba sent text messages to friends with an invitation to attend. Please bring a blanket, lights, snacks, and a drink of your choice. Let's have a catch up, play some sophisticated music, watch the sunset and take it from there." Included with the text was a Google Maps screenshot of the party's destination, a 250-acre park with open fields and small woods called Friant Country Park. It was located near Bieber's home of Wembley in north-west London. One person who was able to attend the celebration was Bieber's younger half sister, 27-year-old Nicole Smallman. Nicole, who was a freelance photographer and artist, lived in the neighbouring town of Harrow. Despite their 20-year age difference, the sisters were close, and Nicole helped Bieber prepare for the picnic. That evening, the two went to a supermarket to purchase snacks, then headed
比巴没有被吓倒，她给朋友们发了短信邀请。请带上毯子、灯、零食和你选择的饮料。让我们聚一聚，放点优雅的音乐，看日落，然后随心所欲。”短信中附有一张聚会目的地的谷歌地图截图，这是一个占地250英亩、拥有开阔田野和小树林的公园，名叫弗莱恩特乡村公园（Fryent Country Park）。它位于比巴在伦敦西北部温布利（Wembley）的家附近。能够参加这次庆祝活动的人之一是比巴同父异母的妹妹，27岁的妮可·斯莫尔曼（Nicole Smallman）。妮可是一名自由摄影师和艺术家，住在邻近的哈罗镇（Harrow）。尽管她们有20岁的年龄差，但姐妹俩关系亲密，妮可还帮比巴准备了野餐。那天晚上，两人去超市买了零食，然后前往
to Fryant Country Park in Bieber's Purple Audi. Video footage from London's expansive CCTV network captured the two walking into the park side by side at 7.39pm, chatting together and smiling as they carried their supplies. The sisters selected a spot at the top of a hill, scattering cushions and blankets around. They had also brought some fairy lights and glow sticks to add a party atmosphere and provide light after the sun went down. As Bieber's friends started to arrive, the sisters waved the lights in the air to draw their attention. The spot where they were seated afforded a scenic view of London and everyone snapped photographs of the pink and purple streaked sky as the sun set and dusk fell. There was singing, dancing, laughing and chatting, as well as lots of eating and drinking.
弗莱恩特乡村公园，开的是比巴的紫色奥迪车。伦敦庞大的闭路电视网络拍摄的视频片段捕捉到了两人于晚上7点39分并肩走进公园的画面，她们一边聊天一边微笑着，手里提着补给品。姐妹俩选了一个山顶的位置，在周围铺上了垫子和毯子。她们还带了一些仙女灯和荧光棒，以增加派对氛围，并在太阳下山后提供照明。当比巴的朋友们开始到达时，姐妹俩在空中挥舞着灯光以吸引他们的注意。她们坐的地方可以俯瞰伦敦的风景，大家在日落和黄昏降临时拍下了粉紫色交织的天空。大家唱歌、跳舞、欢笑、聊天，还吃喝了很多东西。
When it became dark and the hour grew late, Bieber's guests began to depart. One by one, the partygoers said goodbye and headed home until just Bieber and Nicole remained. Left alone to enjoy some time together, the two sisters chatted, danced and snapped photographs of themselves playing with the fairy lights. Throughout the night, Nicole had been texting her boyfriend Adam via the messaging platform WhatsApp. texting her boyfriend Adam via the messaging platform WhatsApp. At 1.04am she sent him a message that read, I'm dancing in a field, accompanied by an emoji of a woman dancing. She followed up with another text, Going home soon. The The following morning of Saturday June 6, Wilhelmina Smallman decided to text her daughters, Bebo and Nicole, to see how their picnic had gone. Wilhelmina, who went by the nickname Mina,
天黑且时间渐晚时，比巴的客人们开始离开。聚会的人一个接一个地告别回家，直到只剩下比巴和妮可。两人独处享受时光，聊天、跳舞，并拍下她们玩仙女灯的照片。整晚，妮可一直在通过即时通讯平台WhatsApp给她的男友亚当发短信。凌晨1点04分，她给他发了一条消息：“我在田野里跳舞”，并附上了一个跳舞女人的表情符号。随后她又发了一条短信：“很快就回家。”第二天，即6月6日星期六早上，威廉敏娜·斯莫尔曼（Wilhelmina Smallman）决定给她的女儿们比巴和妮可发短信，看看她们的野餐过得怎么样。威廉敏娜（昵称米娜），
had been unable to attend Beba's party as she lived in the coastal town of Ramsgate, located almost 80 miles east from London in the county of Kent. But Bieber and Nicole had made sure to send Mina photos from the celebration the previous night. Their family was close-knit. As well as Bieber and Nicole, Mina had a third daughter, Monique, who lived in Holland. as Bieber and Nicole, Mina had a third daughter, Monique, who lived in Holland. Bieber and Monique were Mina's children from her first marriage to Herman Henry, a retired boxer. Nicole was her only child from her second marriage to Christopher Smallman. Bieber and Monique were close with their stepfather and everyone got along extremely well. At 11.23am, Mina sent her
因为住在距离伦敦以东约80英里的肯特郡拉姆斯盖特（Ramsgate）海滨小镇，没能参加比巴的派对。但比巴和妮可确保给米娜发了前一天晚上庆祝活动的照片。她们的家庭关系紧密。除了比巴和妮可，米娜还有一个住在荷兰的女儿莫妮克（Monique）。比巴和莫妮克是米娜与退休拳击手赫尔曼·亨利（Herman Henry）第一次婚姻所生的孩子。妮可是她与第二任丈夫克里斯托弗·斯莫尔曼（Christopher Smallman）唯一的孩子。比巴和莫妮克与继父关系亲密，大家相处得非常好。上午11点23分，米娜给她的
daughters a text message in response to some pictures they'd sent of the picnic. Love the photo, good turnout. She added that she hoped they'd had a lovely time and asked them to tell her all about it later on. To her surprise and concern, Mina didn't hear anything back from either of her daughters. Meanwhile, Nicole's circle of friends were also growing concerned. Her boyfriend Adam had asked her to let him know when she arrived home safely, but she never did. Adam got in touch with Nicole's housemate Emma, who said Nicole hadn't come home. The lack of contact was strange. Nicole loved animals and had a pet bearded dragon lizard whom she adored. If she ever planned to be away for a longer period of time,
女儿们发了一条短信，回复她们发来的一些野餐照片。“很喜欢这张照片，参加的人不少。”她补充说，希望她们玩得开心，并让她们稍后再详细告诉她。令她惊讶和担忧的是，米娜没有收到任何一个女儿的回复。与此同时，妮可的朋友圈也开始担心起来。她的男友亚当曾让她到家后报个平安，但她一直没发。亚当联系了妮可的室友艾玛（Emma），艾玛说妮可没回家。这种失联很奇怪。妮可热爱动物，养了一只她非常疼爱的鬃狮蜥。如果她计划长时间外出，
she would provide instructions for his care, such as when to feed him or change his heat lamp. But she hadn't done so this time. Emma contacted some mutual friends to see if they had heard from Nicole. None of them had. After Adam repeatedly called Nicole without success, he tried to trace her phone with a tracker app to no avail. Hoping that Nicole had decided to stay at Bieber's house, Adam travelled there to check. No one was home. By the time Saturday evening rolled around, Adam and Nicole's friends were becoming increasingly upset. When the women's mother Mina conferred with Adam and realised nobody had heard from Bieber or Nicole, she knew something was wrong.
她会提供照顾它的说明，比如什么时候喂食或更换加热灯。但这次她没有这样做。艾玛联系了一些共同的朋友，看看他们是否收到妮可的消息。他们都没有。在亚当多次拨打妮可电话未果后，他尝试用追踪应用定位她的手机，也无济于事。亚当希望妮可决定留在比巴家，于是前往那里查看。家里没人。到了周六晚上，亚当和妮可的朋友们越来越不安。当姐妹俩的母亲米娜与亚当商量并意识到没人有比巴或妮可的消息时，她知道出事了。
At 10.42 that night, Mina called the police to report her daughters missing. She told them what the situation was, how long it had been since anyone had heard from Beba and Nicole, and provided a detailed description of where they were last seen. But Mina got the impression that the police didn't share her concern. They listened to her, but didn't seem to share her sense of urgency, and didn't indicate they would do anything to look for the women. That night, Mina and her husband Christopher couldn't sleep. They continued trying to call and text Bieber and Nicole throughout the night, typing out one message after another.
那天晚上10点42分，米娜打电话给警察报告女儿失踪。她告诉了他们情况，比巴和妮可失联了多久，并提供了她们最后被看到地点的详细描述。但米娜感觉警察并不像她那样担心。他们听了她的话，但似乎并不认同她的紧迫感，也没有表示会采取任何行动去寻找她们。那天晚上，米娜和丈夫克里斯托弗彻夜难眠。他们整晚都在尝试给比巴和妮可打电话和发短信，一条接一条地输入信息。
Where are you? Getting quite worried here? Please let us know you are okay." When Sunday morning rolled around, the women's loved ones knew they would have to do something. It had been more than 24 hours since Beiber and Nicole had been seen. Hoping that getting the word out on social media might help, Nicole's friends posted about Nicole's disappearance on Facebook. They shared a photo of Nicole beneath the heading, Missing. They also started phoning hospitals in the area to see if they had any patients matching the women's description. As the police still hadn't sent out search parties, Christopher Smallman made the decision to drive to London to conduct his own search. Nicole's
“你们在哪里？我们很担心。请让我们知道你们平安。”当周日早上到来时，姐妹俩的亲友们知道必须采取行动了。距离比巴和妮可最后一次露面已经超过24小时。妮可的朋友们希望在社交媒体上发布消息能有所帮助，于是将妮可失踪的消息发到了Facebook上。她们在“失踪”标题下分享了一张妮可的照片。她们还开始给该地区的医院打电话，看看是否有符合她们描述的病人。由于警察仍未派出搜救队，克里斯托弗·斯莫尔曼决定开车去伦敦进行自己的搜寻。妮可的
boyfriend Adam had the same idea. Like Mina, he had called the police the previous night to report his girlfriend missing but hadn't gotten anywhere. The police had told them they would pay a visit to Bieber's flat so Adam and his mother had gone there to wait for them. But the police never showed up and couldn't say when they would arrive. Accompanied by his parents, Adam decided to go to Fryand Country Park, the place where the women were last known to have been. Once at the park, Adam met up with a friend of the sisters named Nina Resmat, who'd attended the picnic on Friday night. Nina had also been concerned after being unable to reach the women and had cycled to the park
男友亚当也有同样的想法。像米娜一样，他前一天晚上也报了警，但毫无进展。警察曾告诉他们会去比巴的公寓看看，所以亚当和他的母亲去那里等他们。但警察一直没出现，也说不出什么时候会到。亚当在父母的陪同下，决定前往弗莱恩特乡村公园，那是她们最后被确认出现的地方。到达公园后，亚当遇到了姐妹俩的一位朋友尼娜·雷斯马特（Nina Resmat），她周五晚上参加了野餐。尼娜在无法联系上她们后也很担心，于是骑自行车来到公园，
by herself hoping to find something. She'd spent about 30 minutes riding her bike around the enormous park looking for her friends. Nina took Adam and his parents to the top of the hill where Bieber's celebrations had been held. The spot was a five minute walk from the Valley Drive entrance to the park. It was surrounded by sprawling fields which were dotted with ponds and framed by denser areas of woodland. No sign of the picnic held two nights earlier remained.
独自希望能找到什么线索。她在巨大的公园里骑车转了大约30分钟寻找她的朋友。尼娜带着亚当和他的父母来到比巴举行庆祝活动的山顶。这个地点距离公园的谷地大道（Valley Drive）入口有五分钟的步行路程。周围是广阔的田野，点缀着池塘，并被更茂密的林区环绕。两天前举行的野餐没有任何痕迹留下。
All of the blankets, cushions, and fairy lights that had been strewn around the top of the hill were now gone. The lack of items belonging to the sisters left the impression that they'd most likely packed up their things and left the park, rather than something happening to them while they were still there. Regardless, the group still decided to search their surroundings. They split up and began scouring the area. While Adam and his parents went in other directions, Nina combed through the large field at the base of the hill looking for anything out of place. Then something caught her eye. A mangled pair of expensive
所有散落在山顶的毯子、垫子和仙女灯现在都不见了。姐妹俩物品的缺失让人觉得她们很可能收拾好东西离开了公园，而不是在她们还在那里时发生了什么事。尽管如此，大家还是决定搜寻周围环境。他们分头开始搜查该区域。当亚当和他的父母向其他方向走去时，尼娜在山脚下的大片田野里仔细搜寻任何异常的东西。然后，有什么东西引起了她的注意。一副破损的昂贵
designer prescription sunglasses lay on the ground, glinting in the sun. Nearby was a long patch of flattened grass. Nina's heart sank. She immediately recognised the glasses as belonging to Biba. The state of them didn't suggest that Biba had left the park safely and of her own accord. Uncertain what she should do now, Nina picked up her phone and called the police to report what she'd found. They told her to hand the glasses in to them, so Nina picked them up and hopped back on her bicycle to go to the nearest police station. She continued to communicate with Adam via text. He'd found nothing, and when he messaged Nina saying that he didn't know what to do, she replied,
设计师处方太阳镜躺在地上，在阳光下闪闪发光。附近有一长片被压平的草地。尼娜的心沉了下去。她立刻认出这副眼镜属于比巴。它们的状态并不像是比巴安全且自愿离开公园的样子。尼娜不知道现在该怎么办，她拿起手机打电话给警察报告了她的发现。他们让她把眼镜交给他们，于是尼娜捡起眼镜，跳上自行车前往最近的警察局。她继续通过短信与亚当沟通。他什么也没找到，当他发短信给尼娜说他不知道该怎么办时，她回复道：
if you can bear it, just keep looking. Adam and his parents continued to search. They called out the women's names, hoping desperately for a reply while searching through scrub and vegetation. Adam spotted a second pair of sunglasses but didn't touch them. Then Adam's father called out to him. Adam rushed over to the location his father was searching. Nearby was a long trail of flattened grass and lying on the ground was a black-handled knife with a 12cm blade. It was engraved with the brand name, Taylor's Eyewitness, and looked clean.
“如果你能承受，就继续找。”亚当和他的父母继续搜寻。他们呼喊着姐妹俩的名字，绝望地希望能得到回应，同时在灌木丛和植被中搜寻。亚当发现了第二副太阳镜，但没有触碰它们。接着亚当的父亲呼唤他。亚当冲向他父亲正在搜寻的位置。附近有一长条被压平的草地，地上躺着一把黑色手柄的刀，刀刃长12厘米。上面刻着品牌名称“Taylor's Eyewitness”，看起来很干净。
Despite the clean blade, the sight left Adam panicked. Pulling out his phone, he dialled 999, the emergency services number, and began explaining the situation to a dispatcher while running along the stretch of flattened grass at the same time. The trail led towards a strip of wooded area with a row of trees. Poking out from beneath some undergrowth was a pair of shoes. Adam ran around to a gap in the bushes. Diving into the undergrowth, he was met with a horrifying sight. About one foot away from him lay the bodies of two women intertwined together. It was Bieber and Nicole. Both lay on their sides and they were positioned top to toe. It looked as though they were locked in an embrace with their limbs wrapped around one another. Bieber's clothing had been pulled up over her head. She had been stabbed eight times and her
尽管刀刃很干净，但这景象让亚当惊慌失措。他掏出手机，拨打了999紧急服务电话，开始向调度员解释情况，同时沿着那条被压平的草地奔跑。小径通向一片有树木的林区。从一些灌木丛下露出一双鞋子。亚当绕到灌木丛的缝隙处。他钻进灌木丛，看到了一幕恐怖的景象。离他大约一英尺远的地方躺着两具交缠在一起的女性尸体。是比巴和妮可。两人都侧卧着，头脚相对。看起来她们像是锁在一起，四肢缠绕着对方。比巴的衣服被拉到了头上。她被刺了八刀，她的
back was covered in abrasions from being dragged through the rough undergrowth. Nicole's clothing had been yanked up above her abdomen and she too had abrasions and stab wounds. But Nicole's injuries were far more extensive than her sister's. She had been stabbed 28 times. Her eyes were open and as Adam looked at his girlfriend's face, he knew that she was dead. He fell to the ground and let out several guttural screams which was heard by the 999 dispatcher on the other end of his phone. His parents also heard Adam's cries of distress and raced over towards him, but he leapt up to stop them from having to see what he'd seen.
背部因为被拖过粗糙的灌木丛而布满擦伤。妮可的衣服被拉到了腹部上方，她也有擦伤和刺伤。但妮可的伤势比她姐姐严重得多。她被刺了28刀。她的眼睛睁着，当亚当看着女友的脸时，他知道她已经死了。他瘫倒在地，发出了几声喉咙深处的尖叫，电话那头的999调度员听到了。他的父母也听到了亚当痛苦的哭喊声，冲向他，但他跳起来阻止他们看到他所看到的一切。
He handed his phone to his father and ordered his parents not to go into the bushes, then collapsed once again. After hearing Adam's screams, a man in another area of the park flagged down a police officer and directed her towards the noise. She found Adam and his parents in a state of shock. The officer and a colleague entered the scene where the sisters' bodies lay and confirmed that both were deceased. Officers from London's Metropolitan Police descended on the park. With the ground stretching for 250 acres, they were facing an enormous crime scene. To preserve the area where Bieber and Nicole's bodies lay, and to prevent it being contaminated
他把手机递给父亲，命令父母不要进入灌木丛，然后再次瘫倒。听到亚当的尖叫声后，公园另一区域的一名男子拦住了一名警察，并将她引向声音来源。她发现亚当和他的父母处于休克状态。这名警察和一名同事进入了姐妹俩尸体所在的现场，并确认两人均已死亡。伦敦大都会警察局的警官们涌入公园。面对占地250英亩的土地，他们面临着一个巨大的犯罪现场。为了保护比巴和妮可尸体所在的区域，并防止其在
before forensic experts had a chance to examine it, officers set up a series of cordons. The innermost cordon framed the hedgerow where the women's bodies were. Mina Smallman was at home waiting anxiously for news when her phone rang with a call from Adam. She answered and Adam told her, Mina, Mina, I need you to sit down. We found them, but they're gone. Mina began to scream uncontrollably. After her cries eventually subsided, she remembered that her husband was driving to Friant Country Park. She phoned Christopher and broke the news to him that their girls had died. Although they knew there was no longer any way to help Beiber and Nicole, some of their loved ones felt a desire to go to the park and be there for them in the only way they could. A small group
法医专家有机会检查之前受到污染，警官们设置了一系列警戒线。最内层的警戒线围住了妇女尸体所在的树篱。米娜·斯莫尔曼在家中焦急地等待消息时，手机响了，是亚当打来的。她接听了，亚当告诉她：“米娜，米娜，你得坐下。我们找到她们了，但她们已经走了。”米娜开始无法控制地尖叫。在哭声最终平息后，她想起丈夫正在开车去弗莱恩特乡村公园。她打电话给克里斯托弗，告诉他他们的女儿们已经去世的消息。尽管他们知道已经无法再帮助比巴和妮可，但她们的一些亲友感到有一种去公园的渴望，以他们唯一能做的方式陪伴她们。一小群人
gathered at the bottom of the hill before the cordons started and watched as forensic units arrived and officers went to and from the scene. As detailed in the BBC documentary Two Daughters, one of Bieber's relatives was extremely distraught and begged the officers to let him see Bieber. We can't do that, one of the officers replied. But we will look after them. We will take care of them. We will respect them. We will promise that." Several officers were installed at the innermost cordon to guard the sisters' bodies until they could be removed for autopsy the following morning. Forensic tents were set up so that members of the public wouldn't see the bodies being taken from the park. Further examinations confirmed that whoever had killed the two women had dragged them by the feet into the bushes and deliberately positioned them in the way they were found,
聚集在警戒线开始前的山脚下，看着法医小组到达，警官们进出现场。正如BBC纪录片《两个女儿》（Two Daughters）中所述，比巴的一位亲属极度悲痛，恳求警官让他见比巴一面。“我们做不到，”其中一名警官回答。“但我们会照顾她们。我们会照顾她们。我们会尊重她们。我们保证。”几名警官被部署在最内层的警戒线处，守卫着姐妹俩的尸体，直到第二天早上可以将她们移走进行尸检。法医帐篷被搭建起来，这样公众就不会看到尸体被从公园移走。进一步的检查证实，杀害这两名妇女的人将她们拖着脚拖进灌木丛，并故意将她们摆成被发现时的样子，
perhaps as a way to further degrade them. 46-year-old Bieber Henry had sustained six stab wounds to her chest, one to her groin, and one to her back. The knife used in the attack had penetrated her lungs and heart, with one chest wound measuring 15 centimetres deep. This particular injury would have rendered Beba unconscious within seconds. She had no defensive wounds, indicating that her killer had caught her by surprise. Her 27-year-old sister, Nicole Smallman, would have been witness to her sister's attack. Unlike Beba, Nicole had numerous defensive injuries and her attack had been far more brutal, likely because she had tried to fight back. She had been stabbed 28 times and had injuries to
也许是为了进一步羞辱她们。46岁的比巴·亨利胸部被刺六刀，腹股沟一刀，背部一刀。袭击中使用的刀刺穿了她的肺部和心脏，其中一处胸部伤口深达15厘米。这种特殊的伤害会在几秒钟内让比巴失去知觉。她身上没有防御性伤口，表明凶手让她措手不及。她27岁的妹妹妮可·斯莫尔曼目睹了对她姐姐的袭击。与比巴不同，妮可有许多防御性伤害，她的袭击要残酷得多，很可能是因为她试图反抗。她被刺了28刀，伤口遍布
her chest, back, thigh, hip, shoulder, arms and hands. Investigators appealed for anybody who had been at Fryant Country Park on the evening of Friday, June 5, or early morning on Saturday, June 6, to come forward. They described the location where Bieber and Nicole had been and said that if anyone had seen or heard anything suspicious, then it was especially important that they share what they knew. Quote, then it was especially important that they share what they knew. Quote, You may have stumbled upon items of property but not realised the significance of them. If you did, you may well have information that could assist us hugely, no matter how insignificant it may seem. Several witnesses did come forward. At 1.45am on the morning of Saturday June 6, a local woman named Elaine Williams had been at home watching television when she suddenly heard a disturbance
胸部、背部、大腿、臀部、肩膀、手臂和手。调查人员呼吁任何在6月5日星期五晚上或6月6日星期六凌晨在弗莱恩特乡村公园的人站出来。他们描述了比巴和妮可所在的位置，并表示如果有人看到或听到任何可疑的事情，那么分享他们所知道的信息就显得尤为重要。引用：“你可能偶然发现了某些物品，但没有意识到它们的重要性。如果你发现了，你很可能拥有能极大地帮助我们的信息，无论它看起来多么微不足道。”几名证人确实站了出来。6月6日星期六凌晨1点45分，一位名叫伊莱恩·威廉姆斯（Elaine Williams）的当地妇女在家看电视时，突然听到
from the direction of the park. It sounded like a man shouting. This was followed by two female voices shouting back. Then Elaine could only hear one woman's voice, followed by a blood-curdling scream. To Elaine, it sounded like a massive argument between two groups who didn't know each other. Later that morning, a man named Martin Ridgeway headed to the park armed with several bin bags. Martin was a member of Barnhill Conservation Group and would spend time picking up rubbish as part of that work. As he made his way through the park looking for litter, Martin came across a large pile of abandoned belongings. There were several cushions, two backpacks, a large blue hold-all bag, a white paper bag, and some food packaging. Some of the items were covered in red marks, which Martin assumed were
从公园方向传来一阵骚动。听起来像是一个男人的叫喊声。随后是两个女人的叫喊声回应。接着伊莱恩只能听到一个女人的声音，随后是一声令人毛骨悚然的尖叫。对伊莱恩来说，这听起来像是两群互不相识的人之间发生了激烈的争吵。那天早上晚些时候，一名叫马丁·里奇韦（Martin Ridgeway）的男子带着几个垃圾袋前往公园。马丁是巴恩希尔保护小组（Barnhill Conservation Group）的成员，他会花时间清理垃圾作为工作的一部分。当他在公园里寻找垃圾时，马丁发现了一大堆被遗弃的物品。有几个垫子、两个背包、一个蓝色大旅行袋、一个白色纸袋和一些食品包装。其中一些物品上覆盖着红色的痕迹，马丁认为那是
ketchup stains, as there were several empty saucepots amongst the detritus. He threw the belongings away in some park bins. Police were later able to track these items down. The following morning of Sunday June 7, shortly before Adam Stone and his parents commenced their search of the park, a woman named Linda Guerrero was walking her pet Beagle Bambi through the grounds. As she passed some bushes near the top of a hill, Linda noticed two bodies entwined on the ground. From the angle where she was standing, Linda could see the bare back of one of the individuals. She assumed they were a couple asleep in an embrace. Sometimes unhoused people would sleep rough in Fryand Country Park, so Linda wasn't
番茄酱污渍，因为在垃圾中还有几个空的酱料盒。他把这些物品扔进了公园的垃圾桶里。警方后来能够追踪到这些物品。6月7日星期日早上，在亚当·斯通和他的父母开始搜寻公园之前不久，一位名叫琳达·格雷罗（Linda Guerrero）的妇女正带着她的比格犬班比（Bambi）在公园里散步。当她经过山顶附近的一些灌木丛时，琳达注意到地上有两具交缠在一起的尸体。从她站的角度看，琳达可以看到其中一个人裸露的背部。她以为那是一对在拥抱中睡着的恋人。有时无家可归的人会露宿在弗莱恩特乡村公园，所以琳达并没有
particularly alarmed by the sight. She called out, are you okay? Are you alright, mate? When there was no reply, Linda continued on her way. She later phoned Streetlink, an organisation that helps rough sleepers in London to report the incident. It wasn't until she learned of Bieber Henry and Nicole Smallman's murders that she realised the significance of what she had seen. Friant Country Park remained closed off to the public while police scoured its grounds for further evidence. A heavy downpour of rain across London on Saturday June 6, the day before the sisters were found, led to fears that evidence had been washed away. This rain was also the reason that the
对这一景象感到特别惊慌。她喊道：“你们还好吗？伙计，你们没事吧？”当没有回应时，琳达继续前行。她后来打电话给Streetlink，这是一个帮助伦敦露宿者的组织，报告了这一事件。直到她得知比巴·亨利和妮可·斯莫尔曼被谋杀的消息，她才意识到她所见之事的严重性。弗莱恩特乡村公园仍然对公众关闭，警察在公园内搜寻更多证据。6月6日星期六，即姐妹俩被发现的前一天，伦敦的一场大雨导致人们担心证据已被冲走。这场雨也是
knife recovered at the crime scene appeared to be clean. But when investigators picked it up, they saw the underside was stained with blood. Testing revealed that the blood belonged to two different people, Nicole Smallman and an unidentified male. Thanks to London's comprehensive network of CCTV cameras, investigators had been able to trace the sisters' actions in the lead-up to the picnic. They had been captured on camera shopping for picnic supplies at a co-op supermarket, and one of the items they purchased was a bottle of tonic water. The bottle was subsequently found in a bush near the women's bodies. It had blood on it. the women's bodies. It had blood on it. Other bottles of rose and prosecco recovered at the scene also had traces of blood on them. A pair of blue latex gloves was also found.
在犯罪现场发现的刀看起来很干净的原因。但当调查人员捡起它时，他们看到底面沾有血迹。检测显示，这些血迹属于两个人：妮可·斯莫尔曼和一名身份不明的男性。多亏了伦敦全面的闭路电视摄像头网络，调查人员得以追踪姐妹俩在野餐前的行动。她们在合作社超市购买野餐用品的画面被摄像头拍到，她们购买的物品之一是一瓶汤力水。这瓶水后来在妇女尸体附近的灌木丛中被发现。上面有血迹。现场回收的其他玫瑰红葡萄酒和普罗塞克葡萄酒瓶上也有血迹。还发现了一副蓝色乳胶手套。
One of the gloves was heavily stained with blood and damaged along the centre as though slashed with a knife. If the killer had been wearing the gloves, it appeared that they had suffered an injury during the attack, most likely when Nicole Smallman had fought back. Investigators were able to obtain a DNA profile from the blood on the bottles, the glove and the discarded items that a member of the public had thrown away. at items that a member of the public had thrown away. It was from the same unidentified male as the blood on the knife. This individual's blood was also found on some vegetation near the women's bodies from one of Nicole's feet and on Beba's trainer's hand and leggings. This blood had likely been left when the killer dragged the women by their feet into the bushes.
其中一只手套上沾满了血迹，中间有破损，就像被刀割开一样。如果凶手戴着手套，看来他在袭击过程中受了伤，很可能是在妮可·斯莫尔曼反抗时。调查人员能够从瓶子、手套和公众扔掉的废弃物品上的血迹中获得DNA图谱。它与刀上的血迹来自同一个身份不明的男性。这个人的血迹也在妇女尸体附近的植被上、妮可的一只脚上以及比巴的运动鞋和紧身裤上被发现。这些血迹很可能是凶手将妇女拖进灌木丛时留下的。
There was no record of this person in the National DNA database. Divers searched a pond in the park for possible evidence. They recovered two smartphones which had belonged to Biba and Nicole. Their killer had seemingly taken them from the scene and subsequently disposed of them. A forensic examination would reveal that the last contact they'd had with friends or family was when Nicole texted her boyfriend Adam just after 1am on the Saturday morning. Between 1.26am and 3.48am, someone had repeatedly tried to gain access to Bieber Henry's phone. Its screen had been turned off and then on again at least 130 times.
国家DNA数据库中没有这个人的记录。潜水员在公园的一个池塘里搜寻可能的证据。他们找回了两部属于比巴和妮可的智能手机。她们的凶手似乎从现场拿走了它们，随后将它们处理掉了。法医检查显示，她们与亲友的最后一次联系是妮可周六凌晨1点刚过给男友亚当发短信时。在凌晨1点26分到3点48分之间，有人多次试图访问比巴·亨利的手机。它的屏幕至少被关闭和打开了130次。
Thanks to a step counter on the phone, police could see that whoever had been holding it had walked about 1.3 miles during that time before switching the phone off and throwing it into the pond. Also found on the device were a number of photos that the sisters had taken throughout the night. There were shots of them celebrating with their friends and then pictures of just the two of them after everyone else had gone home. Bieber and Nicole had set up a timer on the phone's camera, draped themselves with fairy lights and snapped more than a hundred pictures as they laughed and danced in the dark. The final photograph was taken at 1.13am. In this image, the women appeared distracted.
多亏了手机上的计步器，警方可以看到持有它的人在那段时间里走了大约1.3英里，然后关掉手机并将其扔进了池塘。在设备上还发现了一些姐妹俩整晚拍摄的照片。有她们与朋友庆祝的照片，还有其他人回家后她们俩的照片。比巴和妮可在手机相机上设置了定时器，披上仙女灯，在黑暗中一边欢笑一边跳舞，拍了一百多张照片。最后一张照片拍摄于凌晨1点13分。在这张照片中，两人看起来心不在焉。
Instead of posing like they had in the other shots, both were looking to their left as though something in that direction had drawn their attention. Detectives suspected that this was the moment their attacker had made himself known. No one who knew Bieber and Nicole could think of anyone who would want to harm them. Bieber was a highly respected and popular senior social worker at Buckinghamshire Council who went above and beyond for the children she worked with. Bieber had her own daughter whom she adored and was about to become a grandmother for the first time. She made friends easily and was well liked for her positive demeanour. Nicole worked as a freelance photographer and shared
她们没有像在其他照片中那样摆姿势，而是都看向左侧，好像那个方向有什么东西吸引了她们的注意。侦探们怀疑这就是她们的袭击者现身的那一刻。认识比巴和妮可的人都想不出有谁会想伤害她们。比巴是白金汉郡议会一位备受尊敬和欢迎的高级社会工作者，她为她所服务的孩子们付出了超乎寻常的努力。比巴有自己的女儿，她非常疼爱她，而且即将第一次成为祖母。她很容易交到朋友，并因其积极的态度而广受喜爱。妮可是一名自由摄影师，分享着
her sister's upbeat outlook on life. Her parents often joked that she should have been born in the 1960s as she was a flower child at heart who cared deeply about social justice, animals and the natural world. For the past six years she had been in a relationship with her boyfriend, Adam Stone. The couple had lived together with Adam's parents for a while, but Nicole had recently moved into a flat with a housemate. Nevertheless, the pair remained as close as ever. Prior to Nicole leaving for Beba's party, Adam had made sure to give her money so she could catch a cab home. Beba and Nicole also had good relationships with their family members who were highly respected members of the community. Their mother, Mina, was a retired archdeacon in the Anglican church. Mina's father was
她姐姐对生活乐观的态度。她的父母经常开玩笑说她应该出生在20世纪60年代，因为她内心是一个关心社会正义、动物和自然世界的花童。过去六年来，她一直与男友亚当·斯通保持着恋爱关系。这对情侣曾与亚当的父母住在一起一段时间，但妮可最近搬进了一间有室友的公寓。尽管如此，两人的关系依然亲密。在妮可去参加比巴的派对之前，亚当特意给了她钱，让她可以打车回家。比巴和妮可与她们的家人关系也很好，她们的家人是社区中备受尊敬的成员。她们的母亲米娜是一位退休的圣公会教堂副主教。米娜的父亲是
Nigerian and she had been the first black woman to hold that title. There was nothing in either of the women's lives that pointed to them being targeted by someone they knew. This appeared to be confirmed by the killer's DNA recovered at the scene. The fact that it belonged to an unknown male suggested to police that the sisters had been victims of a random attack. Detectives went public with this information, telling journalists that the women were murdered by a stranger and they needed the public's help to find him. The suspect they were looking for had likely suffered an injury during the attack which resulted in significant bleeding. If anyone had seen somebody injured or acting suspiciously around the Friant Country Park
尼日利亚人，她是第一位获得该头衔的黑人女性。在两名妇女的生活中，没有任何迹象表明她们是被熟人盯上的。这一点似乎得到了在现场发现的凶手DNA的证实。它属于一名未知男性的事实向警方表明，姐妹俩是一起随机袭击的受害者。侦探们向公众公布了这一信息，告诉记者这两名妇女是被一个陌生人谋杀的，他们需要公众的帮助来找到他。他们正在寻找的嫌疑人在袭击过程中很可能受了伤，导致大量出血。如果有人看到有人受伤或在弗莱恩特乡村公园附近表现可疑，
area they were urged to report what they knew. A few leads trickled in. Local residents said there had recently been a man hanging about the park following women. He was aged in his 50s. While pursuing these tip-offs, police arrested several different men, but all of them were later released without charges. Some people, including the sister's mother Mina, felt that the brutal double murder wasn't receiving enough press attention to generate worthwhile leads. Although London's media had reported on the crime, it wasn't receiving front-page coverage or a national spotlight. Users of the online forum Web Sleuths complained that they hadn't even heard about the murders until stumbling across a thread on the website. The subdued nature of the coverage
他们被敦促报告他们所知道的情况。一些线索零星出现。当地居民说，最近有一个50多岁的男子在公园里跟踪妇女。在追查这些线索时，警方逮捕了几名不同的男子，但他们后来都被无罪释放。一些人，包括姐妹俩的母亲米娜，认为这起残酷的双重谋杀案没有得到足够的媒体关注来产生有价值的线索。尽管伦敦媒体报道了这起罪行，但它并没有获得头条报道或全国性的关注。在线论坛Web Sleuths的用户抱怨说，直到偶然发现网站上的一个帖子，他们甚至都没听说过这起谋杀案。报道的低调性质
seemed at odds with the terrifying nature of the random attack. Then, two weeks after the murders, news broke that finally seemed to capture the press' attention. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Navigating through the endless meal kit options can feel overwhelming, but Home Chef simplifies the process. With its variety and unmatched convenience, Home Chef stands out from the crowd. Gone are the days of indecision and meal planning stress. Delivered to your doorstep to simplify your cooking experience, Home Chef provides fresh produce with chef-designed recipes. And they've got options for every kind of cook. There are classic meal kits with pre-portioned ingredients and easy instructions, oven-ready kits with pre-chopped ingredients,
似乎与随机袭击的恐怖性质不符。然后，在谋杀案发生两周后，终于出现了一条似乎引起了媒体关注的新闻。案件档案稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集节目的赞助商来支持我们。浏览无穷无尽的餐包选择可能会让人感到不知所措，但Home Chef简化了这个过程。凭借其多样性和无与伦比的便利性，Home Chef在众多选择中脱颖而出。优柔寡断和餐食计划压力的日子一去不复返了。Home Chef将新鲜农产品和厨师设计的食谱送到您的家门口，简化了您的烹饪体验。而且他们为各种类型的厨师提供了选择。有配有预分量配料和简单说明的经典餐包，有配有预切配料的烤箱即食餐包，
and quick microwave meals that assemble in minutes. Home Chef has over 30 options a week and serves a variety of dietary needs, so you don't have to worry about what to make ahead of time. Not only is it convenient, but it's economical too. Home Chef customers save an average of $86 per month on groceries. Olivia LaVoice, host of Casefile Presents series The Bakersfield 3, is loving Home Chef for its convenience and the high quality of the ingredients supplied. She says it's also introduced her to new recipes she wouldn't have otherwise made. For a limited time, Home Chef is offering our listeners 18 free meals plus free dessert for life and of course free shipping on your first box. Go to homechef.com slash case file.
以及几分钟内就能做好的快速微波炉餐。Home Chef每周有超过30种选择，满足各种饮食需求，所以您不必提前担心要做什么。它不仅方便，而且经济实惠。Home Chef客户平均每月在杂货上节省86美元。Casefile Presents系列《贝克斯菲尔德3》（The Bakersfield 3）的主持人奥利维亚·拉沃伊斯（Olivia LaVoice）非常喜欢Home Chef的便利性和所提供配料的高品质。她说它还向她介绍了她以前不会做的食谱。在有限的时间内，Home Chef为我们的听众提供18顿免费餐食，外加终身免费甜点，当然还有首个餐盒免费送货。请访问homechef.com斜杠casefile。
That's homechef.com slash case file for 18 free meals and free dessert for life. You heard that right. Homechef.com slash Casefile. Must be an active subscriber to receive free dessert. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. hand. In June of 2020, 32-year-old police constable Jamie Lewis had worked as an officer with the Metropolitan Police Service for just over nine months.
那是homechef.com斜杠casefile，可获得18顿免费餐食和终身免费甜点。你没听错。Homechef.com斜杠Casefile。必须是活跃订阅者才能获得免费甜点。感谢您收听本集节目的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供高质量的内容。手。2020年6月，32岁的警员杰米·刘易斯（Jamie Lewis）在大都会警察局担任警官仅九个多月。
Prior to joining the Met, as it was known, Lewis had spent several years with the British Transport Police. At 3.30am on the morning of Monday June 8, 2020, Lewis arrived at Fryant Country Park with a number of his colleagues. The bodies of Beaver Henry and Nicole Smallman had been found in the park roughly 15 hours earlier and officers were needed to guard the scene overnight until the bodies could be safely removed. Janie Lewis and several colleagues were assigned to the cordon closest to the sisters' bodies, which weren't visible from where they were standing. The officers were told the general location within the thicket where the women lay, but weren't shown the bodies. None were wearing full barrier
在加入大都会警察局（Met）之前，刘易斯曾在英国交通警察局工作了几年。2020年6月8日星期一凌晨3点30分，刘易斯与几名同事抵达弗莱恩特乡村公园。比巴·亨利和妮可·斯莫尔曼的尸体大约在15小时前在公园被发现，需要警官彻夜守卫现场，直到尸体能被安全移走。杰米·刘易斯和几名同事被分配到离姐妹俩尸体最近的警戒线，从他们站的地方看不到尸体。警官们被告知了妇女们躺在灌木丛中的大致位置，但没有看到尸体。没有人穿着完整的屏障
forensic clothing. They were not to search the woodland area. Their job was simply to keep watch and to make sure no one entered the scene in order to preserve its integrity. Each of the four officers was given a separate post to guard and told they must remain in place until colleagues arrived to relieve them. Under no circumstances were they to enter the bushes where the women's bodies lay. At 3.50am, about 20 minutes after arriving at the park, Jamie Lewis took out his phone and opened the messaging application WhatsApp. He then typed a message to a group chat labelled The 18. Me, Izzy, Dennis and Matt are living the Wembley dream. He attached a photo of a forensic tent set up at the park, then hit send. The group chat consisted of 41 different Metropolitan Police officers. One soon sent a reply,
法医服装。他们不得搜查林区。他们的工作只是保持警惕，并确保没有人进入现场，以保持其完整性。四名警官中的每一位都被分配了一个单独的岗位进行守卫，并被告知必须留在原地，直到同事到达接替他们。在任何情况下，他们都不得进入妇女尸体所在的灌木丛。凌晨3点50分，到达公园约20分钟后，杰米·刘易斯拿出手机，打开了即时通讯应用WhatsApp。他随后给一个名为“The 18”的群聊发了一条消息：“我和伊兹、丹尼斯、马特正在过着温布利梦。”他附上了一张公园里搭建的法医帐篷的照片，然后点击发送。该群聊由41名不同的大都会警察局警官组成。很快有人回复：
enjoying the sunrise. Lewis responded, unfortunately, I'm sat next to two dead birds full of stab wounds. Another officer replied with a joke about Lewis's use of the slang term birds, referring to women. He asked, who's been out stabbing pigeons? Lewis responded by sending a photograph he'd taken of Bieber and Nicole's bodies, despite being instructed not to breach the cordon. One of Lewis's colleagues from the North East London police station, 45-year-old police constable Dennis Jaffa was also using WhatsApp to message nine of his friends in another group chat. He sent the group a Daily Mail article about the double homicide and informed them that
“享受日出。”刘易斯回复：“不幸的是，我坐在两具满是刀伤的死鸟旁边。”另一名警官回复了一个关于刘易斯使用俚语“鸟”（指代女性）的笑话。他问：“谁出去刺鸽子了？”刘易斯回复了一张他拍摄的比巴和妮可尸体的照片，尽管他被指示不要越过警戒线。刘易斯在东北伦敦警察局的一名同事，45岁的警员丹尼斯·贾法（Dennis Jaffa）也在使用WhatsApp给他在另一个群聊中的九个朋友发消息。他给群组发送了一篇关于这起双重谋杀案的《每日邮报》文章，并通知他们
he was at the scene now. He would try to take some photos of the bodies to share with them. Over the next several hours, Lewis and Jaffa repeatedly left their posts to walk back and forth to chat with each other. Both breached the cordon to take multiple up-close photographs of Bieber and Nicole. Jaffa took four photographs, while Lewis took two. Lewis edited one photo in the social media app Snapchat to superimpose his face next to the bodies, as though he'd taken a selfie with them. Both men shared some of their
他现在就在现场。他会尝试拍一些尸体的照片与他们分享。在接下来的几个小时里，刘易斯和贾法多次离开岗位来回走动聊天。两人都越过了警戒线，拍摄了多张比巴和妮可的近距离照片。贾法拍了四张照片，而刘易斯拍了两张。刘易斯在社交媒体应用Snapchat中编辑了一张照片，将他的脸叠加在尸体旁边，就像他和她们拍了自拍一样。两人都分享了他们的一些
photos with friends who didn't work with the police and told them that the two victims were a 14-year-old and a pregnant 20-year-old. It is unclear where they obtained this incorrect information. Lewis referred to Bieber and Nicole as two stabbed up dead women. When Jaffa was asked by a friend if the crime scene was bad, he replied, not really, I've seen worse. Lewis also showed the photos on his phone to several different people in person. Two of these were police officers. One was a female probationary officer. She was disgusted by the photographs and told Lewis his actions were inappropriate. At least one member of the A-Team WhatsApp group who had been sent similar photos agreed and reported the matter to their higher-ups at the Metropolitan Police. On Friday June 19, the Independent Office for
与朋友分享照片，他们没有配合警方，而是告诉对方两名受害者分别是14岁和20岁的孕妇。目前尚不清楚他们从哪里获得了这些错误信息。刘易斯将比伯和妮可称为“两具被捅死的尸体”。当贾法被朋友问及犯罪现场是否很糟糕时，他回答说：“其实还好，我见过更惨的。”刘易斯还当面将手机里的照片展示给了几个人看。其中两人是警察，其中一名是女性实习警员。她对这些照片感到厌恶，并告诉刘易斯他的行为是不恰当的。A小队WhatsApp群组中至少有一名收到类似照片的成员表示同意，并向伦敦警察厅的上级报告了此事。6月19日星期五，独立办公室
Police Conduct, also known as the IOPC, was alerted. Three days later, Lewis and Jaffa had their phones seized and were arrested for misconduct in public office. had their phone seized and were arrested for misconduct in public office. During an examination of Jaffa's phone, it was found he'd also used a racist term to refer to South Asian men. When Lewis received a text using that same term, he made no objection. The Met issued a press release about the arrests and the story quickly made headlines across the UK. Bieber and Nicole's family had the news broken to them in person by a member of the IOPC. For Mina Smallman and the sisters' other loved ones, this was the final straw. They had felt from the start that Bieber and Nicole's case hadn't been taken
警察行为调查局（简称IOPC）接到了通知。三天后，刘易斯和贾法的手机被没收，并因公职人员行为不当被捕。在检查贾法的手机时，发现他还曾使用种族主义词汇来称呼南亚裔男性。当刘易斯收到使用同样词汇的短信时，他没有提出任何异议。伦敦警察厅就此次逮捕发表了新闻稿，该事件迅速成为英国各地的头条新闻。比伯和妮可的家人是由IOPC的一名成员亲自告知这一消息的。对于米娜·斯莫尔曼和姐妹俩的其他亲人来说，这是压死骆驼的最后一根稻草。他们从一开始就觉得比伯和妮可的案件没有得到
seriously. First, there had been the delayed police response when they were reported missing. Mina put this down to racism and classism. Both her daughters were of Nigerian heritage and Biba lived in a public housing flat in Wembley, a predominantly black neighbourhood. As she told the BBC, quote, I knew instantly why they didn't care. They didn't care because they looked at my daughter's address and thought they knew who she was, a black woman who lives on a council estate. Cases involving missing white women from middle class backgrounds seemed to be taken more seriously by the media as well. Mina Smallman would later note that the story about the officer's misconduct generated far more
重视。首先，在她们被报告失踪时，警方的反应迟缓。米娜将其归咎于种族主义和阶级歧视。她的两个女儿都有尼日利亚血统，比伯住在温布利的一个公共住房公寓里，那是一个以黑人为主的社区。正如她告诉英国广播公司的那样：“我立刻就知道他们为什么不在乎。他们不在乎是因为他们看了我女儿的地址，就以为他们了解她是谁——一个住在廉租房里的黑人女性。”媒体似乎也更重视涉及中产阶级背景的白人女性失踪案件。米娜·斯莫尔曼后来指出，关于警察行为不当的新闻所引发的
media attention than the women's disappearance and murder had. But that didn't mean Mina thought the misconduct was unworthy of attention. The news that her daughter's dignity had been further degraded by two people charged with protecting them was utterly devastating for the grieving mother. As she said in an interview with The Guardian, Mina hadn't even imagined what her daughter's bodies looked like until she learnt officers took photos of them. She was already barely holding on by a thread, and now she suddenly began having images flash through her mind of what the crime scene might have looked like. Her pain somehow deepened. Mina told the BBC, quote,
媒体关注度远高于这两名女性失踪和被谋杀的事件。但这并不意味着米娜认为这种不当行为不值得关注。得知女儿的尊严被两名本应保护她们的人进一步践踏，这对这位悲痛欲绝的母亲来说是毁灭性的打击。正如她在接受《卫报》采访时所说，在得知警察给女儿的尸体拍照之前，米娜甚至从未想象过女儿的尸体是什么样子。她当时已经处于崩溃边缘，现在脑海中突然闪现出犯罪现场可能的样子。她的痛苦不知何故加深了。米娜告诉英国广播公司：“
This has taken our grief to another place. If we ever needed an example of how toxic it has become, those police officers felt so safe, so untouchable, that they felt they could take photographs of dead black girls and send them on. It speaks volumes of the ethos that runs through the Metropolitan Police. Bieber and Nicole's friends and family were horrified to think that while they had been standing vigil at the park desperate for one final glimpse of their loved ones, members of the police were taking dehumanising photographs of them and making crass jokes. In the BBC documentary Two Daughters, one of Be Bieber's cousins stated, Those two police officers did something worse than them being murdered. We can't change that. But the dignity that they deserved in their death,
这让我们的悲伤进入了另一个层面。如果我们曾经需要一个例子来证明它变得多么有毒，那就是这些警察感到如此安全，如此不可触碰，以至于他们觉得可以给死去的黑人女孩拍照并转发。这充分说明了伦敦警察厅内部盛行的风气。比伯和妮可的朋友和家人想到，当他们在公园守夜，渴望最后看一眼亲人时，警察却在给她们拍摄非人化的照片并开着粗俗的玩笑，这让他们感到恐惧。在英国广播公司的纪录片《两个女儿》中，比伯的一位表亲说：“那两名警察做的事情比她们被谋杀还要糟糕。我们无法改变这一点。但她们在死后应得的尊严，
they took that from them. And I will never forgive them for that. In the wake of the misconduct allegations, the family and the public's trust in the Metropolitan Police Service took a severe hit. Despite this, detectives continued working to solve the case. The suspect's DNA hadn't matched anyone in the National DNA Database, so detectives asked the National Crime Agency to run it against their records for a familial match. This time, there was a hit. On Tuesday June 30, detectives discovered their suspect was related to a man named Kamal
却被他们夺走了。我永远不会原谅他们。”在行为不当指控曝光后，公众对比伯和妮可家人的同情以及对伦敦警察厅的信任受到了严重打击。尽管如此，侦探们仍在继续努力破案。嫌疑人的DNA与国家DNA数据库中的任何人都不匹配，因此侦探们要求国家犯罪局将其与他们的记录进行比对，以寻找亲属匹配。这一次，有了结果。6月30日星期二，侦探们发现他们的嫌疑人与一名叫卡迈勒的男子有亲属关系
Hussein who had previously received a caution. The DNA indicated the suspect was a close family member of Kamal's, most likely his child. Kamal was from an Iraqi-Kurdish background and had four children with his ex-wife who resided on the south side of London in Eltham. All of the children were school-aged, with the eldest being just 18 years old. Kamal had often worried about his first born who was a boy named Daniel. Kamal would tell a neighbour that Daniel had gotten mixed up with the wrong crowd and he was concerned about the direction he was heading in. Daniel had been in his early teens when his parents split up. It had been an unhappy household prior to the divorce, characterised by yelling and arguments. Both the police and paramedics had
侯赛因，他此前曾收到过警告。DNA显示，嫌疑人是卡迈勒的近亲，很可能是他的孩子。卡迈勒是伊拉克库尔德裔，与前妻育有四个孩子，前妻住在伦敦南部的埃尔特姆。所有的孩子都在上学，最大的才18岁。卡迈勒经常担心他的长子，一个名叫丹尼尔的男孩。卡迈勒曾告诉邻居，丹尼尔结交了坏朋友，他很担心丹尼尔正在走的路。丹尼尔在十几岁时父母就分开了。在离婚之前，家里一直很不幸福，充满了叫喊和争吵。警察和医护人员都
attended the property on more than one occasion. After his marriage ended, Kamal relocated to North London, settling into a residence in Kingsbury, just a short walk from Friant Country Park. But his son Daniel's issues continued. In October 2017, when Daniel was 15, his teachers discovered that he had been accessing far-right propaganda and looking for images of corpses on school computers. and looking for images of corpses on school computers. He was subsequently referred to PREVENT, the UK government's counter-extremism program. PREVENT was designed to stop vulnerable individuals being groomed by and drawn into terrorist organisations such as the extremist Islamist group ISIS. Adolescents such as Daniel, who were isolated and from immigrant backgrounds, were seen as especially susceptible to being radicalised.
不止一次到过这处房产。婚姻结束后，卡迈勒搬到了北伦敦，在金斯伯里定居，距离弗莱恩特郊野公园仅几步之遥。但他的儿子丹尼尔的问题仍在继续。2017年10月，当丹尼尔15岁时，他的老师发现他在学校电脑上访问极右翼宣传内容并寻找尸体图片。随后，他被转介给英国政府的反极端主义项目“预防”（PREVENT）。“预防”项目旨在阻止弱势个人被恐怖组织（如极端伊斯兰组织ISIS）招募和拉拢。像丹尼尔这样孤立且有移民背景的青少年，被认为特别容易受到激进化影响。
Daniel Hussain was assigned a mentor and was discharged from Prevent just over six months later in May 2018. Supervisors determined they had, quote, 2018. Supervisors determined they had, quote, no outstanding concerns at that time with respect to violent extremism or terrorism. They continued to provide support and conducted two further reviews of Daniel over the next year. No additional need for concern was identified and no further interventions were deemed necessary. Armed with the DNA evidence of a familial tie between Kamal Hussein and their suspect, detectives raced to gain access to CCTV footage from various cameras surrounding Kamal's home. It turned out that although Daniel still lived with his mother in Ultum, he had been staying with his father at the time when Beba Henry and Nicole Smallman were murdered. Within an hour and
丹尼尔·侯赛因被指派了一名导师，并在六个多月后的2018年5月退出了“预防”项目。主管们确定他们当时“对暴力极端主义或恐怖主义没有未解决的担忧”。他们继续提供支持，并在接下来的一年里对丹尼尔进行了两次进一步评估。没有发现额外的担忧，也没有认为有必要进行进一步干预。掌握了卡迈勒·侯赛因与嫌疑人之间亲属关系的DNA证据后，侦探们争分夺秒地获取了卡迈勒家周围各种摄像头的监控录像。事实证明，尽管丹尼尔仍然和母亲住在埃尔特姆，但在比伯·亨利和妮可·斯莫尔曼被谋杀时，他一直和父亲住在一起。在一个半小时内，
a half, investigators had recovered some incredibly alarming footage. On the afternoon of Wednesday, June 3, two days before Beba's birthday picnic, Daniel Hussain left his father's address and headed to an Asda supermarket in Collendale, North London. Security cameras captured the slight, dark haired young man wearing a blue jacket and light jeans as he browsed the aisles of the store. He selected a tailor's eye witness knife block which contained a set of five black-handled kitchen knives along with some chewing gum, cans of drink, lemons and two candles. Due to the COVID-19 pandemic, Hussain was wearing a face mask as he shopped.
调查人员恢复了一些令人震惊的录像。6月3日星期三下午，也就是比伯生日野餐的两天前，丹尼尔·侯赛因离开了父亲的住处，前往北伦敦科林代尔的一家阿斯达超市。监控摄像头拍到了这名身材瘦削、深色头发的年轻人，他穿着蓝色夹克和浅色牛仔裤，在商店的过道里浏览。他挑选了一个泰勒眼科医生刀具组，里面包含一套五把黑色手柄的厨房刀具，还有一些口香糖、罐装饮料、柠檬和两支蜡烛。由于新冠疫情，侯赛因购物时戴着口罩。
When he took the items to the checkout to pay for them, a clerk asked to see some proof of age due to his purchase of the knives. Hussain pulled out his passport and removed his face mask so he could be identified. Hussain returned to the Asda later that day to buy some extra-strong Uni-Bond power tape. Two days later, on Friday June 5, Hussain left his father's home again and caught a bus to a Morrison's supermarket to collect some items he'd purchased the day prior on Amazon, a balaclava and two folding shovels. Hussain also bought some alcohol. At 8.40pm, CCTV cameras on Lake Spur Close captured Hussain entering the northeast corner of Fryant Country Park. This wasn't far from the Valley Drive entrance where Beiber Henry
当他拿着这些物品去收银台付款时，店员因为他购买刀具而要求查看年龄证明。侯赛因掏出护照并摘下口罩，以便确认身份。当天晚些时候，侯赛因回到阿斯达购买了一些超强力Uni-Bond胶带。两天后的6月5日星期五，侯赛因再次离开父亲家，乘公共汽车前往莫里森超市，领取他前一天在亚马逊上购买的物品：一个巴拉克拉法帽和两把折叠铲。侯赛因还买了一些酒。晚上8点40分，莱克斯珀小巷的监控摄像头拍到了侯赛因进入弗莱恩特郊野公园的东北角。这离比伯·亨利
and Nicole Smallman had arrived one hour earlier. As he strolled into the park, Hussain was carrying a rucksack and clearly wearing blue latex gloves and a mask. The next time he would appear on camera was almost seven hours later at 3.08am when he was captured leaving the pitch black park and heading in the direction of his father's house. Hussain had removed the pants he'd been wearing earlier and tied his jacket around his waist, leaving his lower legs exposed. His right hand was tucked tightly into his jacket's waistband. CCTV cameras tracked Hussain back to his father's home, which he reached at 4.07am. After he knocked on the front door, his father opened it and Daniel
和妮可·斯莫尔曼一小时前到达的瓦利大道入口不远。当他漫步进入公园时，侯赛因背着一个背包，明显戴着蓝色乳胶手套和口罩。他下一次出现在镜头前是在近七个小时后的凌晨3点08分，当时他被拍到离开漆黑的公园，朝着他父亲家的方向走去。侯赛因脱掉了之前穿的裤子，把夹克系在腰间，露出了小腿。他的右手紧紧塞在夹克的腰带里。监控摄像头追踪侯赛因回到他父亲家，他在凌晨4点07分到达。在他敲门后，他父亲打开了门，丹尼尔
Hussain disappeared inside. At 1am on Wednesday July 1, officers armed with tazers descended on the home of Hussain's mother. The double story brown brick townhouse was one of several identical attached residences that sat side by side in a row on a quiet cul-de-sac. It was mere hours after detectives had discovered the familial DNA link and the incriminating CCTV footage. They knocked on the door and after a few moments a light flicked on inside. A skinny young man pulled back a sheer curtain to look at the waiting officers, then opened the door. The police immediately ordered him to raise his hands and informed him that he was under arrest. Daniel Hussain lifted his hands, placed them on his head, and silently stepped over the threshold.
侯赛因消失在屋内。7月1日星期三凌晨1点，携带泰瑟枪的警察突袭了侯赛因母亲的家。这座双层棕色砖砌联排别墅是安静的死胡同里一排完全相同的住宅之一。就在侦探们发现亲属DNA联系和确凿的监控录像后的几个小时。他们敲了敲门，片刻之后，屋里亮起了一盏灯。一个瘦削的年轻人拉开透明窗帘看了看门外的警察，然后打开了门。警察立即命令他举起双手，并告知他已被逮捕。丹尼尔·侯赛因举起双手，放在头上，默默地跨过了门槛。
Officers handcuffed him and transferred him to Wandsworth Police Station. Multiple injuries were visible on Hussain's right hand. His middle finger had a deep cut near the tip which had been stitched up, and he also had several stitches a centimetre or so below his first finger. When asked about the cuts, Hussain replied, I was getting robbed. Records would show he had visited a hospital the day after the murders and presented with the cuts to his right hand. He initially told staff he'd been mugged the previous night, but he later told the plastic surgeon who treated his injuries that the mugging had been two or three days earlier.
警察给他戴上手铐，并将他转移到旺兹沃思警察局。侯赛因的右手上可见多处伤口。他的中指指尖附近有一道深切口，已经缝合，他的食指下方一厘米左右也有几针。当被问及这些伤口时，侯赛因回答说：“我被抢劫了。”记录显示，他在谋杀案发生后的第二天去过医院，并因右手伤口就诊。他最初告诉工作人员他前一天晚上被抢劫了，但后来他告诉治疗他伤口的整形外科医生，抢劫发生在两三天前。
He didn't want to report the crime to the police. Hussain then told detectives that he had autism spectrum disorder and problems with his memory. After that, he refused to speak further. He answered every question the detectives asked him with the same refrain. No comment. While Hussain was being interviewed, officers searched his mother's home. In Hussain's bedroom, they found a blue latex glove that matched the ones found in Friant Park. In his wardrobe, they found the balaclava and one of the folding shovels that Hussain had bought one day before the murders. The other folding shovel was never found,
他不想向警方报案。侯赛因随后告诉侦探，他患有自闭症谱系障碍，记忆力有问题。此后，他拒绝再说话。他用同样的回答回应了侦探提出的每一个问题：“无可奉告。”在侯赛因接受审讯时，警察搜查了他母亲的家。在侯赛因的卧室里，他们发现了一只蓝色乳胶手套，与在弗莱恩特公园发现的手套相匹配。在他的衣柜里，他们发现了侯赛因在谋杀案发生前一天购买的巴拉克拉法帽和其中一把折叠铲。另一把折叠铲从未找到，
nor were the jacket or the trousers Hussain had been wearing on the night in question. nor were the jacket or the trousers Hussain had been wearing on the night in question. A book of spells was found in Hussain's room along with some hand-drawn pictures of what looked like occult symbols. Officers also found a piece of paper taken from a loose leaf folder that was covered in handwriting. It was headlined, agreement. Below that was what appeared to be a kind of contract. It read, For the mighty king Lucifuge Rofecal, Perform a minimum of six sacrifices every six months for as long as I am free and physically capable. Sacrifice only women. Build a temple for you. Do everything that I have promised. For me. Win the Mega Millions Super Jackpot. To receive fruitful rewards in return for the future sacrifices I make to you. The rewards could consist of wealth and power.
侯赛因案发当晚穿的夹克或裤子也没有找到。侯赛因的房间里发现了一本咒语书，还有一些手绘的看起来像神秘符号的图片。警察还发现了一张从活页夹中取出的纸，上面写满了字。标题是“协议”。下面似乎是一份合同。上面写着：“致强大的路西法格·罗法卡尔国王，只要我自由且有能力，每六个月至少进行六次祭祀。只祭祀女性。为你建造一座神庙。做我承诺的一切。为了我。赢得超级百万大奖。以换取我未来为你进行的祭祀所带来的丰厚回报。回报可能包括财富和权力。”
the rewards could consist of wealth and power. To never be suspected of any crimes by the police, and also that the police will never know of any crimes that I have done and that I will do. At the bottom of the page were the words signed by, followed by spaces for two signatures. by spaces for two signatures. One was for King Lucifuge Rofical and was left blank. The other was assigned to Daniel, who had signed his name in blood. Casefile will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. DNA tests would confirm that the blood on the contract belonged to Daniel Hussain. His fingerprints were also all over the document. Research would uncover that Lucifuge Rofecowl was a demon named in the 18th or 19th century book, The Grand Grimoire.
回报可能包括财富和权力。“永远不被警察怀疑犯罪，警察也永远不会知道我做过和将要做的任何犯罪。”页面底部是“签署人”字样，后面留有两个签名空间。一个是给路西法格·罗法卡尔国王的，留为空白。另一个是给丹尼尔的，他用血签下了自己的名字。Casefile稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本期节目的赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本期节目的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供高质量的内容。DNA测试证实合同上的血迹属于丹尼尔·侯赛因。他的指纹也遍布这份文件。研究发现，路西法格·罗法卡尔是18或19世纪书籍《大魔法书》中提到的一个恶魔。
This occult text contains instructions for summoning demons and contains a, quote, hierarchy of hell, a list of different evil supernatural beings and their roles. According to the Grand Grimoire, Lucifuge Rofecowl is supposedly in charge of Hell's government and treasury. Investigators realised they had just uncovered a motive. Hussein had seemingly believed that if he murdered victims as sacrificial offerings to a demon he believed in, then he would win the lottery, gain power, and escape police attention. Hussain's misogynistic views led to him deciding to only target women. Another document found in Hussain's possessions was a handwritten letter to another demon named
这本神秘文本包含了召唤恶魔的说明，并包含了一个所谓的“地狱等级”，列出了不同的邪恶超自然存在及其角色。根据《大魔法书》，路西法格·罗法卡尔据称负责地狱的政府和财政。调查人员意识到他们刚刚发现了一个动机。侯赛因似乎相信，如果他谋杀受害者作为他所信仰的恶魔的祭品，那么他就会赢得彩票，获得权力，并逃避警方的注意。侯赛因的厌女观点导致他决定只针对女性。在侯赛因的物品中发现的另一份文件是写给另一个名为
Queen Byleth. In this note, Hussain requested that the demon make a particular girl at his school fall in love with him and believe that he was the only person for her. He also wanted to be more attractive to women romantically. In exchange for these things, Hussain would burn incense every two weeks, make offerings of sweet drinks and chocolate, burn red candles, and shed more blood. Based on these documents, it was clear that Daniel Hussain had intended to kill more women. Yet in the four weeks since Biber and Nicole's murders, there had been no further slings. Detectives believed this was due to the hand injuries Hussain sustained during the crime. He was unable to even make a fist with his right hand, which prevented him from attacking more
拜勒斯女王的恶魔的手写信。在这张纸条中，侯赛因请求恶魔让学校里的某个女孩爱上他，并相信他是她唯一的人。他还希望在浪漫方面对女性更有吸引力。作为交换，侯赛因每两周会焚烧香料，提供甜饮料和巧克力，点燃红蜡烛，并流下更多的血。根据这些文件，很明显丹尼尔·侯赛因打算杀死更多的女性。然而，在比伯和妮可被谋杀后的四周里，没有发生进一步的袭击。侦探们认为这是因为侯赛因在犯罪过程中手部受伤。他的右手甚至无法握拳，这阻止了他攻击更多
victims. It was also exactly what had brought him to their attention. was also exactly what had brought him to their attention. Daniel Hussain refused to provide police with a blood sample, but agreed to let them take a swab of his cheek. After this swab was tested for DNA, it was confirmed that the blood of the unknown male at the scene was a billion times more likely to have come from Hussain than from anyone else. He appeared stunned upon learning they were able to receive these results when he had refused to give them his blood. On Thursday June 4, the day before Bieber's party, Hussain had set up an online betting account with LottoGo.com, which ran bets on the Mega Million Super Jackpot. His bank records indicated he had placed five Mega Millions bets and one Mega Millions Syndicate bet on Sunday,
受害者。这也正是他引起他们注意的原因。丹尼尔·侯赛因拒绝向警方提供血液样本，但同意让他们采集口腔拭子。在对该拭子进行DNA检测后，证实犯罪现场未知男性的血液是侯赛因留下的可能性比其他人高出十亿倍。当他得知在拒绝提供血液的情况下他们仍能获得这些结果时，他显得惊呆了。6月4日星期四，也就是比伯派对的前一天，侯赛因在LottoGo.com上开设了一个在线博彩账户，该网站经营超级百万大奖的投注。他的银行记录显示，他在周日进行了五次超级百万投注和一次超级百万联合投注，
June 7. This was the lottery named in Hussain's blood-signed contract and its price total was £321 million. Next to the contract, officers found three lottery tickets purchased on Tuesday June 9. Hussain had also purchased some online scratch card games. In total, he had spent £162.88 trying to win the lottery in the days after the murders. None of his attempts were successful. An examination of Hussain's electronic footprint showed that he was fixated by the occult. Just a few hours prior to his arrest, Hussain had gone online and logged into a forum that was owned by an American man named E.A. Kawedding. Kawedding was a misogynist, a neo-Nazi, and a kind of occult influencer. Unlike more mainstream pagan religions such as Wicca, which emphasise nature-based
6月7日。这就是侯赛因用血签署的合同中提到的彩票，其奖金总额为3.21亿英镑。在合同旁边，警察发现了6月9日星期二购买的三张彩票。侯赛因还购买了一些在线刮刮乐游戏。在谋杀案发生后的几天里，他总共花费了162.88英镑试图赢得彩票。他的所有尝试都没有成功。对侯赛因电子足迹的检查显示，他沉迷于神秘学。就在他被捕前几个小时，侯赛因上网并登录了一个由美国人E.A.科廷拥有的论坛。科廷是一个厌女者、新纳粹分子，也是一种神秘学影响者。与威卡教等更主流的强调自然基础的异教不同，
spirituality, Kawedding's occultism encouraged violence and harmful practices. The forum he ran was part of a larger website where Koh-Wetting sold merchandise, shared spells and occult instruction and offered one-on-one classes to followers. In his writings, Koh-Wetting encouraged people to commit ritualistic murders, instructed them on selecting victims, and described how to kill someone with a knife. Coetting was affiliated with a self-described satanic neo-Nazi group in the US called the Order of Nine Angles, or ONA. While most people who identify as Satanists or atheists who don't believe in deities at all, ONA members do believe in the devil and other demonic entities. Between 2019 and 2021,
科廷的神秘学鼓励暴力和有害行为。他经营的论坛是一个更大的网站的一部分，科廷在那里销售商品、分享咒语和神秘学指导，并为追随者提供一对一课程。在他的著作中，科廷鼓励人们进行仪式性谋杀，指导他们选择受害者，并描述如何用刀杀死某人。科廷隶属于美国一个自称撒旦新纳粹组织的“九角教团”（ONA）。虽然大多数自称撒旦教徒的人是根本不相信神灵的无神论者，但ONA成员确实相信魔鬼和其他恶魔实体。在2019年至2021年间，
seven young men sentenced for neo-Nazi charges had been radicalised by the ONA's content. neo-Nazi charges had been radicalised by the ONA's content. Daniel Hussain had joined Coedding's forum two years earlier, in March 2018. At the time, he was being assessed and supervised by the counter-terrorism program Prevent. They were monitoring him for signs of Islamic extremism, but nothing was found. After Prevent stopped checking up on Hussain, his obsession with demons only grew, as did his misogyny. In one post to Coetting's forum, Hussain described himself as a psychic vampire and said he felt a natural connection with some supernatural beings and demons. Hussain bragged that he was skilled in some areas of magic but needed to practice more to keep up
七名因新纳粹指控被判刑的年轻人受到了ONA内容的激进化影响。丹尼尔·侯赛因在两年前的2018年3月加入了科廷的论坛。当时，他正在接受反恐项目“预防”的评估和监督。他们正在监测他是否有伊斯兰极端主义的迹象，但什么也没发现。“预防”停止对侯赛因进行检查后，他对恶魔的痴迷只增不减，他的厌女症也随之加深。在科廷论坛的一篇帖子中，侯赛因称自己为“通灵吸血鬼”，并说他感到与一些超自然存在和恶魔有天然的联系。侯赛因吹嘘说他在魔法的某些领域很熟练，但需要多加练习以保持
his abilities. He said he particularly loved Satanism and Norse magic and was a big fan of EA Coetting. He had even learnt his first spell, which was a love spell, from Koedding. Hussain asked other posters for advice on creating demonic packs. It appeared that Hussain's contract with Lucifuge Rofical had been directly inspired by Koedding's work. Koedding told his followers that this particular demon was the one to enter into packs with, but added they would also have to take real world action to ensure their wishes would be fulfilled. He provided detailed instructions for writing up such packs, including that the contract writer should request wealth and sign the document in their own blood. The packs should also be brought before
他的能力。他说他特别喜欢撒旦教和北欧魔法，并且是E.A.科廷的忠实粉丝。他甚至从科廷那里学会了他的第一个咒语，即爱情咒语。侯赛因向其他发帖者寻求关于创建恶魔契约的建议。看起来侯赛因与路西法格·罗法卡尔的合同直接受到了科廷作品的启发。科廷告诉他的追随者，这个特定的恶魔是适合签订契约的，但补充说他们还必须采取现实世界的行动来确保他们的愿望得以实现。他提供了撰写此类契约的详细说明，包括合同撰写者应请求财富并用自己的血签署文件。契约也应在烛光下带到
the demon by candlelight. When Hussain bought the knife he used to kill Beber and Nicole, he also purchased some candles. Karwedding's real name was Matthew Lawrence and he was based in Utah. He had a number of prior convictions for drugs and weapon possession charges. At the time of Hussain's arrest, Colwetting had a large social media following, with 128,000 followers on Facebook and 87,000 YouTube subscribers. After the link between Colwetting and Hussain was made, a public backlash would lead to these platforms removing Colwetting and his content. However, as of the date of this episode's release,
恶魔面前。当侯赛因购买杀死比伯和妮可的刀时，他也购买了一些蜡烛。科廷的真名是马修·劳伦斯，他住在犹他州。他有许多关于毒品和武器持有指控的前科。在侯赛因被捕时，科廷在社交媒体上拥有大量粉丝，在Facebook上有12.8万名粉丝，在YouTube上有8.7万名订阅者。在科廷和侯赛因之间的联系被建立后，公众的强烈反对导致这些平台删除了科廷及其内容。然而，截至本集发布之日，
e-commerce site Amazon still sells numerous books co-authored by Colwetting. Detectives were unable to uncover the extent of Daniel Hussain's radicalisation as he refused to provide the passwords to his laptop and iPad. He had also thrown his phone away so it wouldn't fall into police hands. This prevented the police from accessing 80% of Hussain's data. The UK's Crown Prosecution Service, or CPS, took the matter to the US courts in an attempt to force Apple to hand over the data. However, the American judge ruled against their application, finding that the CPS had an offered evidence that there was anything on Hussain's devices that would directly link him to the murders.
电子商务网站亚马逊仍在销售大量由科廷合著的书籍。侦探们无法揭开丹尼尔·侯赛因激进化的程度，因为他拒绝提供笔记本电脑和iPad的密码。他还扔掉了手机，以免落入警方手中。这阻止了警方获取侯赛因80%的数据。英国皇家检察署（CPS）将此事提交给美国法院，试图强迫苹果公司交出数据。然而，美国法官驳回了他们的申请，认为CPS没有提供证据表明侯赛因的设备上有任何直接将他与谋杀案联系起来的内容。
When Mina Smallman found out her daughters died due to their killer believing in demons, she actually felt a sense of strength. As a retired Anglican Archdeacon, she found solace in her faith, telling the BBC, This is my territory. I understand this. I'm the light. He's the darkness." Daniel Hussain was charged with two counts of murder and one count of possession of a knife with intent. He entered a plea of not guilty. Hussain was adamant that the person shown in the CCTV footage was not him and said his bank card used to purchase the knives had been stolen. He'd reported the matter to his bank almost two weeks after the murders. Hussain also claimed that the demonic pact found in his room didn't belong to him, though he offered no explanation for how his fingerprints and DNA came to be on it. His trial began one year after the murders, on Wednesday,
当米娜·斯莫尔曼发现她的女儿们是因为凶手相信恶魔而死时，她实际上感到了一种力量。作为一名退休的圣公会副主教，她在信仰中找到了慰藉，告诉英国广播公司：“这是我的领域。我理解这一点。我是光。他是黑暗。”丹尼尔·侯赛因被控两项谋杀罪和一项持有刀具意图犯罪罪。他拒不认罪。侯赛因坚称监控录像中显示的人不是他，并说他用来购买刀具的银行卡被偷了。他在谋杀案发生近两周后向银行报告了此事。侯赛因还声称在他房间里发现的恶魔契约不属于他，尽管他没有解释他的指纹和DNA是如何出现在上面的。他的审判在谋杀案发生一年后的星期三开始，
June 9, 2021. Bieber Henry and Nicole Smallman's loved ones testified about how they'd found the women's bodies during a search of the park, while detectives and forensic experts detailed all of the evidence tying Hussain to the double murder. Prosecutors theorised that Hussain had selected the two sisters to be his first victims after having his attention drawn by the fairy lights they were carrying. He had lain in wait under cover of darkness at the park, watching the two sisters as they danced together and laughed on the hilltop. Then he launched his attack. Hussain didn't testify in his own defence. His legal team pointed to the fact that two Metropolitan police officers were found to have breached the crime scene to take photos of
2021年6月9日。比伯·亨利和妮可·斯莫尔曼的亲人作证说，他们在搜查公园时是如何发现她们的尸体的，而侦探和法医专家详细说明了将侯赛因与这起双重谋杀案联系起来的所有证据。检察官推测，侯赛因在被她们携带的仙女灯吸引后，选择了这对姐妹作为他的第一批受害者。他躲在公园黑暗的掩护下，看着这对姐妹在山顶上一起跳舞和欢笑。然后他发动了袭击。侯赛因没有为自己辩护。他的法律团队指出，两名伦敦警察厅警官被发现闯入犯罪现场给
the sisters' bodies. They argued that this may have compromised evidence, but provided no explanation as to how Hussain's blood could have otherwise been found at the scene. Hussain's behaviour in court disturbed those present. He kept trying to make eye contact with Bieber and Nicole's mother, Mina Smallman, made L-shaped loser signs at a paramedic witness who was testifying, and turned his back on the judge. After a month-long trial, the jury found Daniel Hussain guilty on all counts. Hussain continued his disrespectful behaviour during his sentencing hearing. Appearing via video link due to an outbreak of COVID-19 on his prison wing, Hussain smiled and tossed his face mask into the air while waiting for court proceedings to commence.
姐妹俩的尸体拍照。他们辩称这可能破坏了证据，但没有解释侯赛因的血是如何出现在现场的。侯赛因在法庭上的行为让在场的人感到不安。他一直试图与比伯和妮可的母亲米娜·斯莫尔曼进行眼神交流，对正在作证的医护人员做出L型“失败者”手势，并背对法官。经过一个月的审判，陪审团裁定丹尼尔·侯赛因所有罪名成立。侯赛因在量刑听证会上继续他的不尊重行为。由于他所在的监狱区爆发新冠疫情，他通过视频连线出庭，在等待法庭程序开始时，侯赛因微笑着将口罩扔向空中。
He also squatted on his chair throughout the hearing instead of sitting upright. When it came time for the judge to pass her sentence, Hussain turned away from the camera. Undeterred, the judge spoke about the horror Hussain's actions had inflicted on his victims' loved ones, stating, "...I am sure that you performed these murders as part of that bargain which you thought would bring you wealth and power. Well, the wealth and power did not arrive, and nor did it happen that the police never found out about your crimes. Your DNA was all over the crime scene, there was a vast amount of CCTV to track you and other evidence to prove it was you. You were tracked down and your plan failed. Bizarre though your pact with the devil may appear to others,
他在整个听证过程中也一直蹲在椅子上，而不是坐直。当法官宣判时，侯赛因背对着摄像头。法官没有被吓倒，谈到了侯赛因的行为给受害者亲人带来的恐惧，并指出：“……我确信你执行这些谋杀案是你认为会给你带来财富和权力的交易的一部分。好吧，财富和权力没有到来，警察也没有因为不知道你的罪行而没发现。你的DNA遍布犯罪现场，有大量的监控录像来追踪你，还有其他证据证明是你。你被追踪到了，你的计划失败了。尽管你与魔鬼的契约在别人看来可能很离奇，
this was your belief system. Your own commitment to the murder of innocent women. Despite Daniel Hussain citing his autism spectrum disorder as a mitigating factor, the judge found that this had no bearing on his decision to commit his crimes. She sentenced Hussain to life in prison with a minimum of 35 years. Because he was under the age of 21, he could not be given a whole life tariff. Bieber and Nicole's mother, Mina Smallman, spoke outside court after Hussain's sentencing and expressed her relief at his capture. Quote, "...if he hadn't been caught, four other families may have been suffering what we have. Although Mina was grateful Hussain had been stopped, it didn't ease her devastation at losing her daughters. She stated, "...no one expects their children to die before them,
这是你的信仰体系。你对自己谋杀无辜女性的承诺。”尽管丹尼尔·侯赛因将他的自闭症谱系障碍作为减轻处罚的因素，但法官认为这对他的犯罪决定没有任何影响。她判处侯赛因终身监禁，最低刑期为35年。因为他未满21岁，不能被判处终身监禁。比伯和妮可的母亲米娜·斯莫尔曼在侯赛因被判刑后在法庭外发言，表达了她对他被捕的宽慰。她说：“……如果他没有被抓住，其他四个家庭可能正在遭受我们所经历的痛苦。”尽管米娜很感激侯赛因被阻止了，但这并没有减轻她失去女儿的毁灭性打击。她表示：“……没有人期望他们的孩子死在自己前面，
but to have two of your three children murdered overnight is just incomprehensible. Attending court has been heartbreaking. The fear that both girls must have gone through in their final moments, trying to save each other and fighting for their lives. That boy, Daniel Hussain, has not only shown that he has no respect for the court, but that he has no remorse for what he has done or the pain he has caused. For those who loved Biba and Nicole, Hussain's senseless motive added to their grief. As a long-time family friend told the BBC, family friend told the BBC, there was a moment of sheer disbelief. To find out it was to do with just trying to win the lottery, it was beyond tragic. It's insulting. If it wasn't bad enough already. Such a banal reason. It was insulting and defensive. Their grief was further compounded by the feeling that they had
但一夜之间有两个孩子被谋杀是不可理解的。出庭令人心碎。两个女孩在生命的最后时刻一定经历过恐惧，试图互相拯救并为生命而战。那个男孩，丹尼尔·侯赛因，不仅表现出对法庭的不尊重，而且对他所做的事情或他造成的痛苦没有悔意。”对于那些爱比伯和妮可的人来说，侯赛因毫无意义的动机加剧了他们的悲伤。正如一位长期家庭朋友告诉英国广播公司的那样，有一瞬间是纯粹的难以置信。发现这只是为了试图赢得彩票，这简直太悲惨了。这是一种侮辱。如果这还不够糟糕的话。如此平庸的理由。这是侮辱性的，也是防御性的。他们的悲伤进一步加剧，因为他们觉得他们
been let down by the authorities as well. Although Mina Smallman had nothing but praise for the detectives who solved her daughter's case, she was devastated by the initial delay by police in taking their disappearances seriously and the actions of the Met officers who took and shared photos of their bodies. The fact that so many officers also received these images in group chats and failed to raise the alarm was just as distressing. At around 9pm on Wednesday March 3, 2021, a 33-year-old woman named Sarah Everard left a friend's house near Clapham Common in South London and began walking to her home in Brixton Hill. When she failed to meet her boyfriend as planned the following day, he reported her missing and a search was quickly launched. CCTV footage would reveal that Sarah had walked for about half an hour before being
也被当局辜负了。尽管米娜·斯莫尔曼对破获她女儿案件的侦探们赞不绝口，但她对警方最初在认真对待她们失踪问题上的拖延，以及伦敦警察厅警官拍摄并分享她们尸体照片的行为感到震惊。这么多警官在群聊中收到这些图片却未能报警，这同样令人痛苦。2021年3月3日星期三晚上9点左右，一名叫莎拉·埃弗拉德的33岁女性离开伦敦南部克拉珀姆公地附近朋友的家，开始步行前往她位于布里克斯顿山的家。当她第二天未能按计划与男友见面时，他报告她失踪，搜寻工作迅速展开。监控录像显示，莎拉步行了大约半小时后被
stopped by an off-duty Met Police officer named Wayne Cousins who was driving a rented car. He flashed his police badge at Sarah and falsely arrested her for breaching COVID-19 guidelines by being out without permission. An investigation would reveal cousins had strangled Sarah, then disposed of her remains in a pond on a property he owned. He had been plotting to kidnap and kill a woman for some time, and Sarah had been his randomly selected victim. woman for some time, and Sarah had been his randomly selected victim. Sarah Everard's murder led to a widespread backlash across London. For many people, her death was an example of another pandemic gripping the United Kingdom – male violence against women. Vigils were held in memory of Sarah and to protest the fact that she had been killed while
一名叫韦恩·卡曾斯的下班伦敦警察厅警官拦住，他当时开着一辆租来的车。他向莎拉出示了警徽，并以她在没有许可的情况下外出违反新冠防疫准则为由，虚假逮捕了她。调查显示，卡曾斯勒死了莎拉，然后将她的遗体处理在他拥有的一处房产的池塘里。他策划绑架和杀害一名女性已经有一段时间了，而莎拉是他随机选择的受害者。莎拉·埃弗拉德的谋杀案在伦敦引发了广泛的强烈反对。对许多人来说，她的死是英国正在发生的另一种流行病的例子——针对女性的男性暴力。人们举行守夜活动以纪念莎拉，并抗议她被杀的事实，而她当时
just going about her life as she had every right to do. But the Met Police broke up these vigils and made a number of violent arrests in the process. They said this was because attendees were in breach of COVID restrictions. To many Londoners, the Met Police's actions were unacceptable. One of their own had been responsible for murdering a young woman, and it appeared that those protesting his crime were experiencing harsher penalties than the perpetrator had in the past for prior offences. News broke that Wayne Cousins had a history of committing sexual assault. He had been accused of indecent exposure on three separate occasions. Each time, police had either failed to investigate or take action against him. One woman said when she had tried to report
只是在过着她完全有权过的生活。但伦敦警察厅驱散了这些守夜活动，并在过程中进行了多次暴力逮捕。他们说这是因为参加者违反了新冠限制措施。对许多伦敦人来说，伦敦警察厅的行为是不可接受的。他们自己的人竟然负责谋杀了一名年轻女性，而且似乎那些抗议他罪行的人所经历的惩罚比肇事者过去因先前罪行所受的惩罚还要严厉。新闻爆出韦恩·卡曾斯有性侵犯史。他曾三次被指控猥亵暴露。每次，警方要么未能调查，要么未能对他采取行动。一名女性说，当她试图举报
Cousins, the police had laughed at her. In 2018, Cousins sexually assaulted a drag queen at a pub. Five officers came under scrutiny for having shared grossly offensive material with Cousins prior to Sarah Everard's murder. One officer involved in the initial search for Sarah shared an offensive meme about her case on social media. Several med officers opted to give Cousins positive character references during his sentencing for the murder, and female officers came forward to say they felt unable to report inappropriate conduct by male colleagues. Public trust in the Metropolitan Police was at an all-time low, for Mina Smallman at all felt sickeningly familiar.
卡曾斯时，警察嘲笑了她。2018年，卡曾斯在一家酒吧性侵了一名变装皇后。五名警官因在莎拉·埃弗拉德被谋杀前与卡曾斯分享极其冒犯性的材料而受到审查。一名参与莎拉初步搜查的警官在社交媒体上分享了一张关于她案件的冒犯性表情包。几名伦敦警察厅警官选择在卡曾斯因谋杀罪被判刑时为他提供积极的性格证明，女性警官站出来说，她们觉得无法举报男性同事的不当行为。公众对伦敦警察厅的信任降至历史最低点，对米娜·斯莫尔曼来说，这一切感觉令人作呕地熟悉。
She felt a tremendous amount of grief for Sarah Everard's family. In an interview with the BBC, Mina stated, I know what that family, the parents, will be going through. And it is a hell. You can't begin to understand what it is to lose a child under those circumstances. And then to have a further betrayal by the very organisation who is paid and we have an agreement with that they will protect us, they will honour us, and behave in a way that gives our deceased dignity." At the same time, Mina couldn't help but notice the stark difference between the amount of attention and public outrage Sarah's case had received in comparison to her daughter's.
她为莎拉·埃弗拉德的家人感到巨大的悲伤。在接受英国广播公司采访时，米娜说：“我知道那个家庭，那些父母，将会经历什么。那是一种地狱。你无法开始理解在那种情况下失去孩子是什么感觉。然后还要受到那个我们付钱给它、我们与它有协议的组织的进一步背叛，他们本应保护我们，尊重我们，并以一种给予我们死者尊严的方式行事。”与此同时，米娜不禁注意到莎拉的案件与她女儿的案件在关注度和公众愤怒程度上的巨大差异。
Where investigators took Sarah's disappearance seriously from the start, Beiber and Nicole's loved ones had to organise their own search parties. This led to the extremely traumatic result of Nicole's boyfriend Adam being the one to discover their bodies. There was wall-to-wall coverage of Sarah Everard's case, in stark contrast to the amount of attention Beiber and Nicole received. contrast to the amount of attention Beiber and Nicole received. Women's magazine Grazia reflected on the discrepancy between the two cases in an article headlined – Where is the outrage for Nicole Smallman and Beiber Henry? Mina told the BBC – I think the notion of all people matter is absolutely right, but
当调查人员从一开始就认真对待莎拉的失踪时，比伯和妮可的亲人不得不组织自己的搜寻队。这导致了极其痛苦的结果，即妮可的男友亚当成为了发现她们尸体的人。莎拉·埃弗拉德的案件得到了铺天盖地的报道，这与比伯和妮可受到的关注形成了鲜明对比。女性杂志《Grazia》在一篇标题为“对妮可·斯莫尔曼和比伯·亨利的愤怒在哪里？”的文章中反映了这两个案件之间的差异。米娜告诉英国广播公司：“我认为‘所有人的生命都很重要’这个概念绝对是正确的，但
it's not true. Other people have more kudos in this world than people of colour. That's what gives me purpose, if their lives make a change in the way women are viewed, and black women in particular. Because in the pecking order of things, we are the lowest on the ladder. in the pecking order of things, we are the lowest on the latter. The Metropolitan Police issued a statement in response to the public anger against them. It read in part, The murder of Sarah Everard is the most horrific of crimes, but we recognise this as part of a much bigger and troubling picture. There have been other murders of women in public spaces, including the killings of Nicole
这不是真的。在这个世界上，其他人比有色人种拥有更多的声望。这就是赋予我目标的原因，如果她们的生命能改变女性，特别是黑人女性被看待的方式。因为在事物的等级制度中，我们处于阶梯的最底层。”伦敦警察厅就公众对他们的愤怒发表了一份声明。声明部分写道：“莎拉·埃弗拉德的谋杀案是最可怕的罪行，但我们认识到这是更大且令人不安的图景的一部分。在公共场所还发生了其他针对女性的谋杀案，包括妮可的遇害。”
Smallman and Bieber Henry. All of these bring into sharp focus our urgent duty to do more to protect women and girls. They reported that there would be a review of Met Police culture and standards, with an urgent review of all current investigations into allegations of sexual misconduct and domestic abuse against Met officers. They also published a new action plan for tackling violence against girls and women. Jamie Lewis and Dennis Jaffa, the two officers who had photographed Beiber and Nicole's bodies, both pleaded guilty to misconduct in public office. Lewis was instantly dismissed from the force, while Jaffa had already resigned by the time he faced court. In December 2021, both men were sentenced to two years and nine months in jail. They would later
Smallman和Bieber Henry。所有这些都让我们更加清醒地认识到，我们有迫切的责任采取更多行动来保护妇女和女童。他们报告称，将对伦敦警察厅的文化和标准进行审查，并对目前所有针对伦敦警察厅警官的性行为不端和家庭虐待指控的调查进行紧急审查。他们还发布了一项打击针对女童和妇女暴力行为的新行动计划。Jamie Lewis和Dennis Jaffa这两名拍摄了Bieber和Nicole尸体的警官，均承认了公职人员行为不当的罪名。Lewis被立即开除，而Jaffa在出庭前就已经辞职。2021年12月，两人均被判处两年零九个月监禁。他们后来
unsuccessfully appeal this sentence. The Metropolitan Police's then-Assistant Commissioner, Helen Ball, said that the men's colleagues were appalled by their actions and that the public couldn't have confidence in their organisation if the force didn't take their behaviour seriously. Quote, I'm sorry that our officers behaved in such a hurtful, disrespectful and criminal way. Their actions are shameful. Three other officers who had received the images without challenging or reporting them all received written warnings but were permitted to keep their jobs. The Independent Office for Police Conduct, or IOPC, held a separate inquiry into how the police handled initial reports that Beber Henry and Nicole Smallman were missing. They found that
上诉失败。伦敦警察厅时任助理局长Helen Ball表示，这些警官的同事对他们的行为感到震惊，如果警方不认真对待这种行为，公众就无法信任他们的组织。引用她的话说：“我很抱歉我们的警官表现得如此伤人、不尊重且违法。他们的行为是可耻的。”另外三名收到照片但未提出质疑或举报的警官都收到了书面警告，但被允许保留工作。独立警察投诉办公室（IOPC）对警方如何处理Bieber Henry和Nicole Smallman失踪的初步报告进行了单独调查。他们发现
the Metropolitan Police had failed to follow their missing persons policies and made other errors. When a friend of one of the sisters called the police asking for help, the call handler was dismissive and referred to one of the missing women as a suspect. Information from a family member as to where the sisters might be was inaccurately recorded and led to an inspector cancelling the report. The IOPC found that the Met Police's response to the case was below the standard that it should have been. However, they didn't find that this was due to any racial bias against the women. The Met offered an official apology to the women's families,
伦敦警察厅未能遵守其失踪人口政策，并犯了其他错误。当其中一位姐妹的朋友打电话给警察寻求帮助时，接线员态度冷漠，并将其中一名失踪女性称为嫌疑人。来自家庭成员关于姐妹俩可能所在位置的信息被错误记录，导致一名督察取消了报告。IOPC发现伦敦警察厅对该案件的反应低于应有的标准。然而，他们并未发现这是由于对这些女性的任何种族偏见所致。伦敦警察厅向这些女性的家人正式道歉，
with then-Commissioner Dame Cressida Dick stating, While we know that very sadly Nicole and Bieber had been murdered in the early hours of Saturday, June 6, 2020, before they were reported missing, if we had responded better we may have saved their friends and family in measurable pain. I am very sorry that the level of service we provided fell short." Mina Smallman responded, quote, "'Sorry is something you say when you comprehend the wrong you do and take full responsibility for it. Demonstrating that by taking appropriate proportionate action which to our minds is not going to happen. The investigation was not handled appropriately. The apology should have been done face to face
时任局长Dame Cressida Dick表示：“虽然我们非常悲痛地得知Nicole和Bieber在2020年6月6日星期六凌晨被谋杀，在她们被报告失踪之前，但如果我们反应更好，我们或许能让她们的朋友和家人免受巨大的痛苦。我非常抱歉我们提供的服务水平未达标。”Mina Smallman回应道：“‘抱歉’是你理解自己所犯错误并承担全部责任时说的话。通过采取适当且相称的行动来证明这一点，而在我们看来这不会发生。调查处理得不恰当。道歉本应面对面进行，
and not nearly 10 months later. Mina rejects the finding that there was no racial bias behind the Met's mishandling. Bieber-Henry and Nicole Smallman's loved ones suffered irreparable damage as a result of their murders. Mina Smallman's sister, the women's aunt, had cancer and suffered a rapid decline after losing her nieces. After she died, Mina said, "...you can't exclude that a broken heart doesn't help a person who is terminally ill." The women's sister, Manique, went from being one of three siblings to an only child. Beba's only daughter gave birth to her first child, a boy, after her mother's murder. Those who knew Beba said that her death was a loss to the entire community. She had been a fierce
而不是在近10个月后。Mina拒绝接受关于伦敦警察厅处理不当背后没有种族偏见的结论。Bieber-Henry和Nicole Smallman的亲人因她们的谋杀案遭受了无法弥补的伤害。Mina Smallman的姐姐，也就是这两个女孩的姨妈，患有癌症，在失去侄女后病情迅速恶化。在她去世后，Mina说：“……你不能排除心碎对绝症患者没有影响。”这两个女孩的姐妹Manique从三个孩子中的一个变成了独生女。Bieber唯一的女儿在母亲被谋杀后生下了她的第一个孩子，一个男孩。认识Bieber的人说，她的去世是整个社区的损失。她曾是一位坚定的
advocate for the vulnerable members of society who came into her care as a social worker. She was also a voracious and fun person with a larger-than-life personality described as just fantastic to be around. Her father, Herman Henry, said he was in agony without her, describing Bieber as a beautiful, outgoing, strong-minded and intelligent woman. Mina Smallman said that although Beba was barely five foot tall, she had the heart of a lion and a smile that would put the Blackpool illuminations to shame, a reference to an annual lights festival in Blackpool, England. Where Beba was described as a beacon, a friend of Nicole said she had a gentler energy.
倡导者，为她作为社会工作者所照顾的社会弱势群体奔走。她也是一个充满活力和乐趣的人，个性鲜明，被形容为相处起来非常棒。她的父亲Herman Henry说，失去她让他痛苦不堪，他形容Bieber是一位美丽、外向、思想坚定且聪明的女性。Mina Smallman说，虽然Bieber身高不到五英尺，但她有一颗狮子般的心，笑容足以让布莱克浦灯饰节（Blackpool illuminations，英国布莱克浦的一年一度灯光节）黯然失色。如果说Bieber被形容为一盏明灯，Nicole的朋友则说她有一种更温和的能量。
Quote, when she walked into a room she was like a nightlight. It was subtle, protective, warm. Easy going and kind hearted, Nicole was a humanitarian who was passionate about the arts and seen as a joy to be around. In his victim impact statement in court, Nicole's partner Adam spoke of his devastation at losing her. To put into words how I feel about losing Nicole is almost impossible, especially in this unimaginable and horrifically violent way. Nicole is my first thought, my second, and every thought thereafter, and if I am lucky enough to fall asleep then I see her in my dreams. This is all I have left of her. Nicole was the only child of her school teacher father, Chris, and had been particularly close to him.
引用她的话说：“当她走进房间时，她就像一盏小夜灯。它是微妙的、保护性的、温暖的。”Nicole随和且心地善良，是一位热衷于艺术的人道主义者，被视为一个相处起来充满快乐的人。在法庭上的受害者影响陈述中，Nicole的伴侣Adam谈到了失去她的毁灭性打击。“用语言表达我失去Nicole的感受几乎是不可能的，尤其是在这种难以想象且极其暴力的方式下。Nicole是我第一个念头，第二个念头，以及此后的每一个念头，如果我有幸入睡，那么我会在梦中见到她。这就是我留下的关于她的一切。”Nicole是她身为教师的父亲Chris的独生女，与他特别亲近。
Mina Smallman told The Guardian, I remember watching him kissing her newborn head. He was completely smitten. For a man who is not sentimental, it was a beautiful thing to see." In the BBC documentary Two Daughters, Mina concluded by saying she wanted people to remember how her daughters lived, not how they died. Quote, "...Bieber, the amazing social worker who battled to make sure children were safe, that families weren't broken up. And Nikki, she was just a ray of light everywhere and I know that will always be the way. And I think that's what we need to do.
Mina Smallman告诉《卫报》：“我记得看着他亲吻她刚出生的头。他完全被迷住了。对于一个不感性的人来说，那是一个美丽的景象。”在BBC纪录片《两个女儿》中，Mina最后说，她希望人们记住她女儿们是如何生活的，而不是她们是如何死去的。引用她的话说：“……Bieber，那位为了确保孩子们安全、家庭不被拆散而奋斗的了不起的社会工作者。还有Nikki，她到处都是一束光，我知道那永远会是这样。我认为这就是我们需要做的。”
We need to find the sunshine in the rain. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们需要在雨中寻找阳光。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。